Travis Kelce pro-bowl tied under the
Kansas City Chiefs back here in the Rich
Eisen show how are you Travis which it
is always a pleasure
great I can't complain okay
I cannot wherever I found you and you
are you in your car leaving the
facilities everywhere I've got you
wherever I go not leaving your facility
just on a lunch break okay all right
yeah grab her lunch and we'll hit a hit
the practice got a nice sunny day out
okay now on occasion you're coming
across as muffled is that the beard and
in like full bloom that your phone is
pressing against full beards actually
she is not anymore
but I'm just wondering are you getting
used to that beard still is that because
I mean that thing is that thing is
getting a cough drop level you know you
know you know I in the beginning of camp
just because it was getting it was
getting too hot nice embrace the
hairiness by the way that we could
rename our fantasy team map that by the
way all right that time Travis Kelce
Brock what is this the first member of
our fantasy team that we've gotten to
interview I think I think we talked to
Derek Carr over the offseason nobody
during the season the season Kelso
Travis if you don't mind I'm just gonna
just be blunt what the hell was with the
one catch one yard one target my
apologies you know but all I can really
see is that on the way to win I don't
think it was a very pretty game if you
ask anybody on the team I don't think it
was a very pretty game offensively but
just based off of that you know I mean
we put ourselves in some bad situations
some of the options are getting me the
following in a prime situations kind of
got limited well you guys obviously have
had success over the last couple of
years with Andy Reid now Alex Smith at
the quarterback spot this to me okay
feels different feels different it just
looks different it feels different it
feels super if you don't mind me saying
I mean how does it how does it feel to
you being in I'll tell you what it's
been
a boost of momentum every single year
that I've been here so I came in with
Coach Reid here in Kansas City and every
single helix feeling like I'm there were
more and more together we're more and
more the better unit we we keep we've
checked a lot of the court artists so
the leadership is there and it's like
yeah like you said man I feel super it
really doesn't feel special right now
it's gonna maintain the hard work during
the week and going out there performing
on our own game well it definitely looks
more dynamic and it's in and some of the
big plays that we're seeing we're just
it just wasn't there I mean you know
we're not seeing those 15 play 9 minute
drives that result in three points we're
just not seeing that feel man it is it's
a work to do with that is uh is a
mindset there's a lot to do with it it's
time to kill I mean there but there's no
secret there than the guys anybody in
the NFL and when you get into poly
didn't even roll on anybody I mean a guy
like that opens up the field for
everybody
how is Kareem hunt I mean what is it
like being around him I mean just a
couple miles away from and it's uh it's
been a pleasure to handle on a team man
this is a TV he's a very humble kid
what's his pillar
didn't really see much to anybody other
than you know I mean let's go out here
get this win and he's fun to be around
well I think his play has been
eye-opening everybody Travis Kelce here
on the Rich Eisen show to me again from
my seat when he fumbled to start his
career and he never fumbled at Toledo
and he fumbled to start his career I if
you guys do wind up going very deep if
not all the way the fact that Andy Reid
put him right back on the field may be
the moment that everybody can look back
and say it would have gone differently
if he took some of that old-school
approach that you fumble you don't play
what was that like to you when you saw
him trot back on the field Travis
everybody that's on the field
you know whoever's opportunity is the
hand belong you know world blush
superfluous to make sure that that guy
had to take to the house because I truly
believe that all of our skill players
have that type of play in them every
time they touch the boat civil arm I
mean obviously you're handling adversity
the first play of the game for us first
play of the year for us when I would
turn it over well yeah that's a fluke in
our mind yeah that doesn't happen
wearing with the cane see cheese we
don't turn almost that sorry about so we
just go out there and just play us
through football
Travis Kelce Chiefs tight end here on
the Rich Eisen show has a knee read
changed at all since you first came
across him not really I mean he put your
noses to the flooring go to work you
know he's not he's not really gonna
change much of this system or how he how
he does things just because that's the
discipline that's the foundation of all
of his teams is that is that when he
calls on you he he needs a reaction he
needs it needs accountability that
you're gonna start doing the right
things so he's he's pretty pretty steady
and then and then still the same old any
reason I know well in terms of
discipline and accountability what does
he say to you and say you take the
football and stick it in somebody's van
noise pretty good thank you sir um you
know what he just tells me to control it
control it I mean the guy who was doing
small stuff like pushed me in the back
pushed pushed me in the back of the
helmet after plays I mean this is
something else go to a normal game I'm
telling the refs but obviously the rest
um I had other interests on the field
but it was it was something I just got
to be able to control I mean it's uh he
doesn't really say much other than
control it you're better than that
we knew we know that they're those kind
of guys that they're gonna try and get
under your skin because frankly when it
comes to playing defense there are they
they were getting torched well I mean
but you are you know look you know how I
feel about you so I come straight
through the front door with you okay no
because you know though that pleat
people are gonna say we can get and
Kelsey said we can get in Kelsey said
we're gonna get him a 15 you know that
so what goes what does go through your
head with my pride the private of
somebody when I'm on the when I'm on the
ground somebody using my neck and using
my face to push off of um just grinding
there they're helpful into my neck
that the not even at the bottom of town
just after a tentacle and the rest not
doing anything about it there's a little
bit of pride there for me I just got to
be able to you know hone that kind of
disrespect is disrespect and it's a it's
a line me but I mean heck when I'm going
to somebody's neck and then trying to
put the Duncans on his face you know I'm
gonna push you on to me that's for sure
Travis Kelce couple more minutes but no
I was gonna get a flag for pushing
somebody off Hey look at this point you
know you've had Flags come your way
every now and then so I guess maybe it's
even reps might say let's let's keep an
eye on 87 and that's probably what Andy
Reid is trying to help you with in all
in all honesty but look you guys are 300
right now you're you're really you're
really looking terrific as a team and
you got a Redskins team did you see what
they did to the Raiders last week
watching that for sure I didn't watch it
live and I've seen every clip they even
filmed from it and it was a it was a
husband show him by the Raiders that's
for sure okay now last night I don't
know if you were able to watch the
Thursday night game the the Danny
Trevathan hit on Davante Adams did you
see that Travis um I've seen replays
didn't see alive okay and haven't seen
it on a fast or a regular speed all I've
seen is the slow-motion clips and man it
was a is aggressive necessary so now
what do you think he should be suspended
for that I'd love to get a pass catchers
mentality or not I know you're a big
dude but what do you think about you
know strike zones and obviously they're
moving for defenders who obviously have
a job to do I understand that but what
do you think that's the subject of
discussion time that's tough man it's uh
I never I never watched film and seen
service and to be that kind of guy
and to be honest linebackers I don't
wanted to live for those kind of shots
but when a guy guys being held up by
another teammate those are pretty shot
for anything better to get in there um
in terms of with leading with your head
I mean I just feel like these guys
that's just how that he always tackled
their entire lives was leading with the
crown of their helmet you know it's a
technique that you got to get away from
in the league because you dink for now
not only on the field but off the field
mean fans coming up so every every which
angle so it's um it's tough I'm not
gonna say whether or not I think he
should a shooting I just don't know I
think it's not that's the gray area in
football right now is trying not to take
away the physicality of the game but
still trying to protect the players all
right look forward to seeing out there
on Monday night Travis always and you
yeah I appreciate you brother
Thank You Roland okay and then again
just know that you're not only out there
representing yourself and the Kansas
City Chiefs you are representing
vultures of the ether which I own with
my buddy Chris Brockman here you
represent us you fly our colors as well
Travis okay
that the herring is grown ok very good
yeah hey you know if you want you score
you know act like you're on the phone
and that's a shout out to me and
vultures the ether and folks in this
program I don't know what you got
planned but maybe you could do that
Monday Never Say Never
ok ok let's do that there first things
first crawl before you walk before you
run take care of yourself Travis you
take care of bud all right that's Travis
Travis the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to